I'm in the library of the Royal society in London and the society
has one of the best autograph books in the world.
And this is Keith Moore.
Who's our librarian who is going to introduce me
to the book and show me the most interesting signature.
No, here's the Royal societies charter book. And if we open it,
you'll see immediately what's going on here.
It opens with the Royal code vibes because of course where the Royal society,
and then you will find the Royal societies own coat of arms with the
motto nullius in Verba, take nobody's word for it.
And then the reason it's called the charter book is because the role societies
charters are reproduced in the text on development here.
This is not on paper. This is animal skin. There are other stiffer than paper,
the slightly slick to the touch. Uh, I'm wearing gloves.
So it's harder to feel that, but, um, you can actually,
if you're on your fingers over it, you can feel the nap of the animal,
but you'll see, this is really where the book gets very interesting. Indeed.
The first page of the signatures and, uh,
the head of the list here is Charles. The second,
who was the site first patron,
the man who put the Royal into the Royal society or the Royals here,
the one you've probably heard of is Prince Rupert,
who was interested in science from the Prince Rupert stroke. It is indeed.
So he did do experiments, uh,
after all society and elsewhere has the class drops that he produced, uh,
are quite famous. Each successive Monarch, uh,
and therefore each successive patron of the Royal society gets their own highly
decorated Royal page. And if I turn the page here,
this is the first page where you get the fellowship proper.
So these are the leading scientists from 1660 onwards.
And the book is a continuous record of all of the fellows of the Royal
society. We wanted two notable exceptions.
And if you examine this page,
you'll immediately begin to see the great scientists of the 17th
century.
Here we got there. Then here we go. Robert hook down at the bottom.
Squeezed into the foot of the page. Yes, John Wallace here. And, uh,
John Wilkins, Christopher Wren's on this page as well.
Christopher Wren who built some Paul's cathedral in London.
That's absolutely right.
Well then let's turn the page and see if we can see Newton.
And here he is quite quite a small Sydney.
Sure.
And you can see immediately the man under Isaac Newton is, uh,
being gradually, uh, raised because Newton's so popular.
People will point to his signature and run their fingers along it.
And therefore, um, it's just raising the ink from the surface of developed.
People say, is that really Isaac Newton and rub out the poor guy underneath?
Yeah.
John [inaudible] the astronomer Royal, who is one of the, that you argued with.
And it's interesting that he didn't put his name in the column.
He's put it slightly to one side and just above a Newton.
Do you, is that just a coincidence or think.
It could be a coincidence, but it's, it's a,
it's a nice idea that he just might've decided to get one up on the great man.
This is Edmond Halley, uh, the astronomer sea captain mathematician,
and many of the things beside we know how many signatures are in this book.
I don't think we've ever counted them. And, um, it's interesting, uh,
that, uh, some of them you can see have actually been crossed out.
That's probably non-payment of subscriptions to the role of society. There is,
uh, another Royal page since one of the Georgia's again,
not terribly colorful, but we'll come to some really highly decorated pages,
quite suit. It is in its way,
an almost complete history of science it's stored in a
controlled environmental volts.
So it's brought out when fellows sign the book once a year,
new fellows in terms of its its value. Uh,
nothing like this as they'd been sold at auction.
So it's anybody's guess how much this would cost you. Uh,
but I can see here. Well, here's young Davey just being,
uh, elected a fellow of the Royal society, Humphrey David there.
So he signed the book.
This is John Dalton,
who first propounded the theory of atoms in its modern form.
Yeah. Okay. And this is, uh, uh, Royal page, uh,
role play is created when a new Monarch is put on the throat.
They become patron of the Royal society.
As a serving Monarch is therefore a new page is created for them.
This is William. This is Charles Darwin.
I think scientists already famous when they sign the book.
Uh, not necessarily Darwin is elected in
1839. Uh,
so 20 years before on the origin of species is,
is written and published. Uh,
at this stage he's just returned from his beagle voyage and he's
sorting out specimens and beginning to, uh,
lecture and talk about what he's seen on his voyages.
So he's not really at the point where he's a, uh,
a leading scientist. So he's still quite a young figure.
Uh, but what there are site he is very good at is recognizing potential and
backing winners, but he queen Victoria.
Um.
It is a whole swathe of scientific endeavor in one
volume here we have, uh,
it's a signature of one of the most famous American scientists.
This is Benjamin Franklin. Of course,
he lived in London and he was on council of the Royal society.
Every time I look at it,
I find new signatures and this is really as close as one can
get to of these scientists to see something that's actually
been written by them. This one is one of my favorite signatures.
This is the signature of mental layer.
Every time there are Russian visitors, I showed them the signature.
So the interests of balance here, we have Alfred Russell Wallace.
We saw Darwin's signature.
So here's the other big figure in the evolution story page
1901. And you have the four corners of empire here.
So you have the ostrich kangaroo, all of these and elephant here, Beaver for.
Canada, presumably rather fits right at the foot of this one.
George George is the future King Edward, the eighth,
who was only King for a short time before he emptied.
So we're coming increasingly up-to-date this is the 20th century and two good
signatures at the top of this page is Sigmund Freud.
And the charter book was taken to him.
One of the very rare instances where that's happened, Freud, uh,
had gotten out of the continent.
So this is the period when the Nazis were coming to power,
he had to escape from his home, longtime home in Vienna,
and he ended up in London in Hampstead. Uh,
so the charter book was taken to Hamstead for him to sign.
He was quite infirm at that time.
And there are some nice photographs of Freud in the garden of his Hamstead home
with the charter book and look underneath. We've got Julian Huxley.
They're great, great scientific family, obviously, of course,
a fantastic zoologist and a great figure in popularizing
science. Here's max born.
Good dad.
It's born of course is Einstein's great correspondent,
a fantastic physicist.
Einstein is one of those signatures we wish we had in the book and we don't know
why the Royal society didn't manage to get him because he was a fellow.
He was a fellow, he was elected after his,
his great works and the Nobel prize in 1921. Uh,
he was certainly in London, uh, during the 1930s and 1933.
Uh, but for some reason we didn't manage to get him for the charter book.
And then off, he went to the U S of course.
This is Niels Bohr,
the first person to apply quantum ideas to the structure of the atom.
So this is 1945. The first women were elected to the Royal society. Uh,
there were two of them, Kathleen Lawnsdale and Midori Stevenson. Uh,
Lonsdale is the one people have really heard of. Uh,
so here's Kathleen Lonsdale. So here's my jury.
Stevenson's who else do we have here? Well, here's his bones Wallace of,
of bouncing bomb of fame on the same page.
And here we have Glenn Seaborg after the elements see Bogan was named
and who also discovered a lot of the trends you write in, in my ligaments.
Is Frank whittle.
The inventor of the jet engine is Linus Pauling down here is that
yes. And here's Dorothy Ball Needham.
This is max from Lawan,
who was one of the people who was very important in the development of
crystallography.
Here we go. Now this is the current Royal page.
So the queen is our current patron is head of the list there,
but many of the Royals are on that page. So Prince Charles is on that.
Prince William.
So this year.
Uh, so this is the Japanese and group. Who's very good Marine biologist.
So he gets to sign. And, uh,
I think we have Gustavo Sweden on there as well.
Lisa Meitner the woman scientist after whom element
109 was named Peter Higgs
signature gives mass to the book
and says almost next door to Margaret Thatcher,
who is prime minister was elected.
She calls the big row and no prime minister has been elected since then
on the cruise, under it. And underneath is David Attenborough,
the world famous naturalists.
You get pages where you get four or five fantastically,
big figures, uh, and you know, it's, it's, one's better than the next almost.
So you do get very, very excited when you're looking at it.
If here's another famous name,
w what was the experience like of actually signing the book?
I w I must say I was quite nervous and you can see it's not a
very elegant signature, but I didn't at least blocked it,
even though my name's in the same book as Charles Darwin,
with some of these other people,
when couldn't possibly imagine that I'm on the same level as them,
but it's still quite nice to be recognized.
This is the end of the book. Well, not quite the end of the book.
So this is the last input intake of fellows of the Royal
society from, from last year, from 2013.
Now you can see, uh, there are blank spaces here.
There's a blank space for the obligation or task to be written in and columns
and columns of vellum waiting to be filled up. Uh, and this,
we hope will be the great scientists of the future.
So if you're looking at this movie, uh,
is that you are you one day going to be in the pages of the Royal
society as a signature and its charter book.
You'll have to be very good to get there, but in a way,
that's an incentive to do great science.
[Inaudible].